stucco is one of the oldest construction
materials on the planet
the earliest formulations date back to
ancient greece
and mayan mexico stucco has stuck around
and as an exterior siding it's come a
long way
modern stucco is more attractive and
offers better protection
whether cement or acrylic-based stucco
always starts out as a sticky paste
and that's the great thing about stucco
in this wet and gooey form
it can be worked as it's applied to the
exterior of a building
to achieve a variety of textures
it hardens to provide a tough exterior
that shields the building against the
elements
to mass-produce cement stucco they start
with tons of silica sand
they unload it into a conveyor and
elevator system
which delivers the sand to silos for
storage until needed
they select sand with various grades of
coarseness for different stucco finishes
they mix it with cement lime and other
ingredients
to create the stucco base
[Music]
a technician demonstrates how the
ingredients come together
using this research lab mixer she blends
all the ingredients dry
achieving a consistency that's similar
to cake mix from a box
cement stucco is sold in dry form water
will be added to liquefy the ingredients
on the job site
in this demonstration she also adds
pigment
with a stucco pre-colored there's no
need to paint the building
to mass-produce cement stucco they use
this mega mixer
the operator adds three or four
different pigments
to create a custom color in the dry
stucco batch
large paddle blades spiral vigorously
usually this is a closed operation but
they've opened it up for our camera
after three minutes of mixing the dry
stucco mix is ready for scrutiny
an employee takes a sample and sends it
to the quality control lab for
[Music]
evaluation
at the lab the technician weighs the
stucco mixture and adds water
[Music]
he keeps an eye on the scale to ensure
that the amounts are proportionate
he mixes them and visually checks to
confirm that the pigment and raw
materials
are well dispersed acrylic stucco on the
other hand
calls for an entirely different recipe
they use calcium carbonate instead of
silica sand
and acrylic as a binder instead of
cement
they mix it with water and sell it wet
in a bucket
instead of dry to color it they use a
computerized tint machine
similar to what you find in a paint
store they load the machine with liquid
pigments
and enter a color formula into the
computer
it mixes the pigments to produce the
exact color
and it releases the precise amount
needed
[Music]
they blend the color into the acrylic
stucco and the batch ends up looking
like blue mud
it's now ready to apply to a home no
prep required
[Music]
they also sell acrylic stucco with no
color at all
it's called tint base the pigments will
be added on the job site
where they can be adjusted if needed an
airtight seal keeps the stucco
in its viscous state acrylic stucco
dries quickly like paint
while cement stucco takes 28 days to
totally cure
into a more durable finish
over on the cement stucco line a
rotating machine handles all the
packaging
a suctioning device pulls a paper bag
into position under a spout
which then fills it up
it takes just eight seconds to fill a
90-pound bag
that works out to over 1300 bags per
hour
enough material for 30 houses
the machine transfers the bag to the
conveyor belt
this stucco is now ready to provide a
strong finish to building projects
applied to a building's exterior stucco
can be textured
to suit the homeowner's taste and it
will harden to provide the building with
a tough skin
that's why stucco continues to be part
of the urban landscape
you